[Musique]
à la fin du xvème siècle deux
navigateurs portugais s'approche d'une
inconnue
perdu au croisement de l'équateur et du
méridien de greenwich l'archipel de sao
tomé et principe et apparaît comme un
mirage au milieu de l'océan
ce territoire baigne au creux de
l'afrique de l'ouest au large du gabon
moi
pendant des siècles ce bout de terre a
été la plaque tournante de la traite des
esclaves et du travail forcé sur
d'immenses plantations lempira imposer
un système d'exploitation de la canne à
sucre puis du café et surtout du cacao
les colons portugais ont quitté sao tomé
en 1975 laissant derrière eux des
fantômes les élégante bâtisse des
exploitations agricoles elles sont
restées elle plie sous le poids du passé
on les appelle ici les ressasse
quand on plonge entre leurs murs
décrépis les souvenirs ressurgissent
leurs noms bucoliques tranche avec leur
histoire
porto alegre raté un minable novo
destino saudade
des centaines de familles s'y sont
réfugiés aujourd'hui
nous sommes partis à leur rencontre
découvrir ses habitants tiraillé entre
cet héritage encombrant et un avenir qui
tentent de construire
[Musique]
on
mais
[Musique]
les angolaises ont été chassés et
repoussé par les portugais au sud de
l'île au 19e siècle
c'est donc par nécessité qui sont
devenus des pêcheurs en apnée au filet
où al ahly
certains naviguent encore sur des dons
gosses des pirogues construites dans des
troncs de mûrier ou de fromage et
à porto allègre toute l'économie de la
communauté tourne autour de la pêche
les pêcheurs mais aussi sur un bateau
j'ai appris à pêcher mais ça a été
difficile parce qu'au début je n'aimais
pas du tout qu'ils n'en ont rejeté
c'est la mort
face aux timides qui n a plus tard que
j'ai dû m'accrocher car c'était la seule
chose que je pouvais faire
on est parti pêcher du coin you mais
maintenant on va vendre sa omar yeuse
[Applaudissements]
hélas masculin
l'amour à blavozy
puisqu'on est sortie en mer à 3 en
ajoutant les sous de l'essence on doit
tous partagé en quatre avec le
propriétaire du matin moi mon copain on
partage tout l'argent 4
[Applaudissements]
pour l'instant je n'ai pas encore assez
d'argent pour investir dans du matériel
parce que c'est trop cher
j'ai le projet d'acheter un jour mon
propre équipement soit un moteur sur un
canoë soit un bateau mais pour l'instant
si j'ai pas assez d'argent
le champion
c'est bon ok on gagne le peu que je
gagne ce n'est pas suffisant pour
m'assurer un avis
car j'ai des enfants qui vont à l'école
et je n'ai pas encore préparer leur
avenir je gagne très peu d'argent pour
le travail que je fais
aux cantons un seul boulot on finit par
travailler uniquement pour manger
efficace en bas les vers sont palmés
[Applaudissements]
s'il faut c est presque à nous situer
pêcheurs ont caressé de t'acheter un
show trouve toi un autre boulot pour
compléter la flèche
ces sportifs et c'est aléatoire ce n'est
pas tous les jours que tu vas réussir à
gagner suffisamment pour les besoins de
sa famille ou dur parce que c'est ma
famille
bon déjà bah oui
- said à mon âge
et fasse je suis pêcheur et je vois
aussi du carburant steve
forget mais
je ne vis pas mal
même si je ne gagne pas beaucoup
j'arrive à mettre un tout petit peu de
côté pour me ce jour
rien
certaines ressasse ont été aujourd'hui
réhabilités l'enfance de beaucoup de sao
tomé 1 a été marqué par l'expérience du
travail forcé les conditions étaient
dures mais lorsque les anciens habitants
comme philippe à reviennent dans
l'hérault sas des souvenirs
ressurgissent parfois aussi la nostalgie
on est ici dans une re ca laroussarie
younès
[Musique]
c'est la rosa de mon enfance
je m'appelle philippe aquaré chemin dans
quoi l'intérêt de 47 ans je suis
assistante sociale
moi je préférerais vivre ici que dans
une grande ville grouillante de monde en
salle au ghana est un lieu beaucoup fait
calme où on arrive à surveiller ses
enfants à 1000 en poche fils à leur
donner une meilleure éducation
parce qu on est loin de la société qui
manque de discipline mais je suis plus
mal ou
c'est la maison de patrons
et blanc vivent est ici
pauli à cacao mon père faisait la
sélection du cacao et il le mettait dans
le feu et moi je venais en courant de ce
pic et du cacao pour le machin
[Applaudissements]
singulière qui devrait cru
je me sens fière et heureuse c'est
remâché fille je sens que ma m c'est
toujours un rêve d'être m
par ailleurs j'ai l'impression d'être au
paradis
[Musique]
sao tomé est un des territoires les
moins développés de la planète la moitié
de la population vit sous le seuil de
pauvreté et le pays semble parfois livré
à lui-même
[Musique]
cette situation économique confère dans
la société une place restreinte à la
flamme santoméenne qui doit gérer
l'éducation de nombreux enfants dans des
conditions de vie souvent précaires
les femmes sont pourtant tout aussi
scolarisés est alphabétisée que les
hommes mais elles sont ensuite bien plus
touchés par le chômage et la pauvreté
mayol ici la plupart des femmes restent
au foyer elle s'occupe de la maison j'ai
commencé à aider les mères et quid des
manies faut faire en sorte qu'elle
arrive à gagner un peu d'argent pour
subvenir aux besoins de leur famille et
améliorer un peu leur vie quotidienne
la direction de la protection sociale
vient sur les terrains pour examiner
leurs conditions de liens est fixé le
montant de l'allocation trimestriels
cette allocation n'est pas suffisante
pour qu'une personne puisse réellement
s'en sortir
les rouges tout en douceur aux autres
ils m'ont choqué la fermeture
y a
que faire excusez moi je peux entrer
quel âge as-tu 47,7 non j'ai 46 et la
mère de quatre enfants
non j'en ai six dont deux qui sont déjà
très grande
donc tu as eu six enfants elle est sèche
vélo
ici et sao tomé ce sont toujours les
maires qui se tient des enfants
les pères ne leur prêtent aucune
attention
ouch pompe avec les pairs comme tous les
habitants car la maison donne parfois de
l'argent pour leurs enfants
partent travailler une heure limite à la
maison et que pour manger se préparer
ses sorties refaire leur vie
ce sont vraiment les maires qui
consacrent leur vie aux enfants ici à
sao tomé
rien ça le père de mes enfants par
exemple est parti en angola il ya huit
ans déjà yann elies qu'on n'est même pas
venu une seule fois les voit rose et du
cusm il n'a pas appelé une seule fois
c'est très dur c'est difficile ici
viennent intervalles je n'ai pas de
chant à cultiver je n'ai pas de travail
j'ai des enfants
c'est dur quand elle pour aller
travailler aux champs quand on m'appelle
il faut que je monte tout là-haut sur la
montagne oui alors les week-ends on
prend les enfants et je monte
en réalité la nourriture à sao tomé et
très cher et comme les salaires sont
très bas la population ne peut pas
subvenir à ses besoins pour l'ensemble
des symptômes et pénestin
[Musique]
gkb fait
il est difficile de convaincre tous les
habitants de sao tomé principe est de
limiter les naissances enfin c'est un
mari n'accepte même pas que leurs femmes
participent au programme du planning
familial
je discute avec lui passer les intérêts
que je veux vraiment qu'ils comprennent
que s'ils veulent une amie à
qui des goths avoir des loin d'en faire
profil avoir une famille moins
nombreuses cela leur permettra des
démiurges leurs enfants s'en sortir
sans vent levé
dans d'autres endroits de l'île une
petite révolution s'opère dès ressasse
sont utilisés par les sao tomé 1 pour
faire du commerce
uja matin francisco ramos et j'ai 53 ans
je suis marié je suis ingénieur agronome
c'est quoi comme manière différente une
façon les gens qui habitaient dans la
rossa n'étaient pas considérés au même
titre que ceux qui travaillaient dans la
fonction publique un logo malgré le sang
cette mentalité rester jusqu'à
aujourd'hui ceux qui vivent dans la rue
sauf sont considérés comme des familles
de pau
match mais un jour ou l'autre cette
mentalité disparaît leur maigre saab et
les jours qui vivent dans l'art au sein
seront capables de démontrer ce qu'ils
valent à la prière pour montrer à ceux
qui habitent la ville que eux aussi ont
de la valeur ces engins et un vélo
demain le poivre et une culture qui
rapportent de l'argent ou plutôt le
gagne et ça ça donne de la motivation
injecteurs
consignes nous avons commencé à ce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui
1963 producteurs gauche
[Musique]
tous
nous t'aimons nous avons l'état qui
apporte les infrastructures on a les
producteurs qui rapporte la matière
premier et nous avons un secteur privé
qui achètent le produit fini les vad qui
combat poncin
par conséquent ce partenariat nous donne
des 46 des et ça montre que le poivre
peut aider à lutter contre la pauvreté
combat qui appauvrit
[Musique]
et aux poses lascives moi je peux enfin
rêver hollande rien vais-je ou en rire
je vois l'avenir devant yann me
potable et claudia nahd moi qui n'avais
rien l'internât je commence à avoir un
avenir plus sûr ségo
à
la halle au
hockey
et
je pense qu'il ya une réunion de la
direction aujourd'hui un dinosaure
h quoi et après ça
vous en dira plus et qui est devant
vous
merci
[Musique]
l'idée d'aider les délinquants
ici on est dans l'ancien au sein rio
lima you et aujourd'hui grâce à la
production de poivre la phrase est
complète en train de rmeil à mon
pilotage
[Musique]
n'échoue en même temps là ils sont en
train de traiter le point rouge belgrade
à le boivre a été trempés dans l'eau on
en dise usd j'étais là où la retirer de
cto et a joué les femmes sont en train
de le laver dans le plat mais il faut la
ville ira directement
ses cadeaux
[Applaudissements]
et tac
mais d'après ce que 93 kg ok vous avez
fait tout ça pour moi c'est très bien ce
qu'ils vivent
car d'appel on va plonger le quoi vos
dans une eau à 90° faciliter la
fermentation
des dalles
dans le présent cas celle que nous
utilisons des coques de noix de coco
cola musée et de ça nous permet de
limiter la coupe des armes ordinaires et
de réduire notre impact sur
l'environnement j2ee après saint sauveur
bien
tenté d'invoquer lui mais dont le rayon
pour le chauffer les taillades colo
cagoule mais dans la chambre noire et
ensuite on le fait sécher à dos
ce sont les quatre étapes fondamentales
pour le traitement du pauvre noire une
façade
dac est vrai qu on met ça voilà tu peux
commencer à mettre la récolte de santa
clara et
intégra main à l'époque ces tissus
qualité de maître et un nous essayons de
négocier pour que le lieu soit cédé à la
coopérative ptc la coopérative
et amoros qui s'est trop ça a certes été
abandonnée mais il est une coopérative
qui est dynamique aujourd'hui nasa c'est
une opportunité pour enfin ne ressentent
pas l avis c'est une recette qui était
déjà très riche dans le passé et on veut
faire revivre tout ça l'agresseur
président
francisco gère l'ensemble de la filière
de poivre santoméenne il part
aujourd'hui sur l'île de principe et
aider de nouveaux cultivateurs
principe et c'est la petite soeur de sao
tomé brut est préservé
e
avec son air de jardin d'éden lille a
des allures de renaissance
e
les recensent se nomme ici bella vista
patience à 110 ou porto real
ce confetti volcanique est l'un des
écosystèmes les plus riches de la
planète il est classé depuis 2012
réserve mondiale de la biosphère par
l'unesco
[Musique]
ici le temps semble s'être arrêté
il
[Musique]
la nature est omniprésente et la pluie
généreuse fait pousser une multitude de
plantes endémiques
le poivre est cultivé sur l'île depuis
une dizaine d'années une épice qui
nécessite beaucoup de soin et
d'attention
je
vois
ça manquait sept branches surtout c'est
une branche productrice c'est raide il
faut pas la couper il n'a pas compté
ses les politologues celle ci est
productrice et joie mais c'est plutôt ya
tout juste un an après il faut que la
tâche très précaire
dans ces années-là d'elad d'elad de
l'add on fait on perd
il ya les données d'un délit et savalou
cinq phases et si tu ne fais pas ce
travail tue n'avancera pas allez on va
voir notre plein
les cheveux le cou le dos cet
agriculteur à demander de l'aide à ses
chiens ils se tiennent ils à goudargues
culte et dans sa plantation et moi je ne
veux voir quels étaient ses difficultés
car les difficultés et lui donner une
forme à dire l'europe maud fontenoy son
avantage donc en plein passage dans une
plantation de poivrons m mais avec là
aussi des bananiers qui nous fournissent
les cordes pouvoir attacher les branches
a créé n'attache pas tournage quotas
vous voulez dire à la plante parce que
tu vas bien tu vas bien dormi la fière
que mal à la tête ou en comprimés il
faut parler aux plantes
comme de faux converser avec les plantes
le câliner lors qu'on les aime je t'aime
tu es ma chérie il faut dire tout ça et
alors là elle va vous répondre mais moi
aussi je t'aime beaucoup bisous quand tu
ne dis pas tout ça aux plantes elles se
sentent délaissés
[Musique]
chevillon
dans le sillage de la réussite de
francisco des femmes comme elena ont
pris le virage de la production et de
l'entrepreneuriat ces dernières années à
principe
c'est une figure forte de lille qui ne
laisse personne gérer son commerce à sa
place
je m'appelle elena monteiro al-majd
acosta
quaranta ses 46 ans et je suis
agricultrice
donc on verra balle et a commencé à
travailler là en 2008 mais au début je
ne gagnais presque rien car il fallait
tout remettre en état nettoyez planta
2010 j'ai commencé à gagner de l'argent
avec le café le citron banane le mathaba
là le manioc
village à partir de 2012 on a commencé à
gagner de l'argent avec le poivre je
suis devenu plus indépendante iec
mazauthon
2014 en 2014 je suis devenu responsable
de la filiale d'éduquer magie suis
davantage consacré au poivre je refuse
les autres à faire comme moi encore
parce que c'est un bon produit
d'exportation t'oblige pourtant ça c'est
une plante qui est un bon rendement un
seul pied suffit pour qu'une personne
puisse gueule assez d'argent pour
acheter du sel du savon de l'huile salle
soit wazemmes
avoir un poivrier qui double en
productivité l'agriculteur doit
impérativement faire s'est taillé
une agricultrice comme moi et autonome
les tuteurs pour corriger des boutures
pour implanter
[Musique]
d'après la mise aux normes et moi c'est
bois
ou pas
selma
bon
[Musique]
surtout
pendant les colonisateurs les blogs ils
ont tout abandonné au point
une des structures les séchoirs du grand
magal
et a tout repris plus personne ne
travaillait
l'activité a dégringolé ump drôme calais
somme ou parent peut espérer qu'une
seule chose le retour au système d'avant
c'était la honte pour
ceux qui n'aiment pas le but aujourd'hui
pour tous les cultivateurs de poivre ou
to look alors d'être un des principaux
mais aussi
et de tous les et sur l'export
reviendrait au système d'avant nou camp
final serait de nouveau dépendre ce
serait vraiment vraiment trippant pas
mieux et montrer ce this day ce titre
est restée
bonjour là bonjour rien nous ça va
ça va le travail je t'aime du poisson
du poisson du camp du non
il est dit qu'est ce que tu pourras pas
pour le repas je fume le poisson je le
prépare pour faire un beau lot de fogo
de feu
mélange le poisson frais avec celui qui
fume et tomates oignons piments forts et
huile de palme
[Musique]
c'est pour le mollet de fogo oui pour le
mettre dans la sauce
eagle houtan kian écoute moi au cube
côté jeu doit cultiver tout ce qu'il est
possible de cultiver
pour le manger pour le vendre pour faire
du troc avec du poisson tu l'emmènes sur
le marché et tu verras et nous oui on
n'aura rien à demander à personne poule
fait pousser tout ce que tu mouilles
qu'un peu de ceci un peu de cela
il faut que j'aille coupé ça
je travaille toujours plus je paye
d'autres personnes car je n'ai pas le
temps de tout faire moi-même
pour mettre à frire dans l'huile tu as
du citron pour mettre sur le poisson tu
as du poivre pour assaisonner talion
la terre nous appartient tous qu'on
agisse qu'on dise aux gouvernements de
terre perdu abandonné
par cultiver des bananes plus de poivre
plus de cacao plus de cacao
c'est le message que je veux faire face
et demain nous aurons nos bateaux et nos
avions comme le carnet
la beauté d'huile pour moi
non l'huile de palme
[Musique]
frais
de là
[Musique]
ce
dans le
[Musique]
et
voilà
bien torréfié la couleur par la couleur
qu'il faut
[Musique]
ok les gars
on
la kozah dégâts
[Musique]
attendez
à
[Musique]
il
roger moody pourtant il faudrait que
tous les belges pourquoi en tout
aujourd'hui il est très important de
faire de l'agriculture biologique or 60
home est un petit pays vulnérables et
qui était une honte et je pèse sur nos
parcelles il y a beaucoup d'espèces
d'oiseaux ondes émises par exemple
[Musique]
en faisant de l'agriculture raisonnée
nous préservons l'écosystème de notre
pays
concernés
[Musique]
r
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
on
e
hier matin trois matches c'est une
tortue mal
nommée bout de temps elle était sous
l'eau gelée vue faux j'ai lâché mon
fusil pour aller l'entreprise
comme c'est une tortue à ces jeunes
l'action se passe en quelques secondes
il ne m'a fallu que 10 ou 15 secondes
pour lui retourner la tête
s'est passé avant il pouvait m'arriver
d'attraper 5 à 6 tortues par jour comme
celles atteintes à l'audace si je
vendais sa carapace vu qu'elle est de
race sada
une race qui peut être utilisée pour
l'artisanat cette carapace à de la peur
à l'époque j'aurais pu en tirer une
belle somme
7 5
[Musique]
et où
déchets et j'ai arrêté de chasser les
tortues pour les vendre et les manger
venez les coûts mais
est passé et je suis devenu un
conservateur de torture
pour que les gens arrêtent de les tuer
et
n'hésitera plus pour les vendre
[Applaudissements]
on va l'amener au fond on la voit plutôt
bien
voilà interloqué aux phases i à
contacter un bon gars
et ça marche parce que j'ai infligées
aux tortues il faut je ne le referai
plus jamais
construit
j'étais capable d'en attraper beaucoup
chaque jour car je connaissais que tous
les bons coins là où elle dormait là où
il mangeait on y admire on y recourt
parfois je sortais de chez moi
uniquement pour le plaisir de les tuer
allez
[Applaudissements]
s2 au récit
acquitté tout un tas de dos il ya un peu
d'alcool
y as est ce qu'on connaît mais que j'ai
mis un petit morceau de chair
ces données vont être analysés par la
biologiste qui est le chef du projet
touche est un central où
tu vas être étudiée pour savoir d'où
elle vient et où elle est née et la zone
où elle vit champ d'une anse et au real
et on divise
sa syntaxe haïti
à
c'est maintenant
où
au
début quand je tue et les tortues je ne
savais pas ce que ça représentait une
tortue dans la mer
il y en en sabir qui je ne savais pas
quand les chats sont on dit après leur
cabas en l'espèce tout entière pouvait
disparaître
car cela fait quatre ans que je n'ai pas
vu une seule personne consommer de la
viande de tortue ici à porto l
agneau
quand j'ai chassé les tortues pour les
vendre et les manger
je ne vais pas beaucoup d'affection pour
elle
et aux non katy n'y a pas de catalogue à
je ne vais jamais attrapé une tortue à
mains nues match desproges qui est il
est logique que j'ai arrêté de les tuer
matata l'eau on est devenus comme des
jeux mais on en a
aujourd'hui il est très rare qu'elle
s'échappe en me voyant de l'homme elman
aujourd'hui quand une tortue me croisent
dans l'eau elle s'approche de moi alors
ça c'est maintenant que je ne fais plus
que je faisais dans le passé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
les femmes aussi doivent apprendre à
pêcher
ce n'est pas qu'un travail d'homme pour
les femmes aussi
et ici apprennent chipayas qu un
particulier dans notre zone il ya
beaucoup de femmes qui sont des
travailleuses d'achat neige qui
m'attaquent abattant les deux
fils ont fini aux costauds un fils ou
une fille qui fait des études c'est très
important mais il ya aussi le travail
manuel
qui va l'université quand elle est à la
maison elle a pas travaillé avec la
bêche elle apprend le commerce aussi
elle apprend que ça vaut le coup
travailler dans l'agriculture qui valent
à peine
lancement une paye nos mères autrefois
travaillé pour les blancs
travailler pour les entreprises elle
travaillait pour les
aujourd'hui certains vont leur terre au
lieu de travail et
essayer de prendre exemple sur
la question et surtout de ne pas avoir
faim à la maison moi j'ai plein de
choses qui sont plantés et qui me
permette de vivre
tout ce que je fais me permet d'obtenir
du rendement des monnaies loup et je
n'ai jamais peur glisse je ne suis
jamais paris cela ne dépend de personne
je suis forte
il
et
on entre bien dans le match
mais qui paie mon équipe c'est celle de
monter les enfants que j'ai entraîné
aujourd'hui il joue un match du
championnat
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je mais no global
[Musique]
tous
les autres équipes qui s'entraînent ici
ont un meilleur niveau technique que
nous donner parce qu'ils ont un meilleur
terrain et plus de ballons
mais notre équipe est plus imposante des
joueurs sont de nature plus fort ils
sont plus costauds du monde
alors nos adversaires doivent faire
beaucoup d'efforts prône l'amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
indigo mais dans le passé les gens
disaient n'y vous n'êtes qu'un grain de
sable sur la carte vous n'avez pas votre
mot à dire
mais moi je reste persuadé que même si
on est un petit pays peut devenir une
nation du fort
parce que nous avons un niveau
d'éducation élevé que la jeunesse de ce
pays veut voir autre chose d'avoir une
vision du monde différente à cause des
autres habitants
au bout du monde il ya eu une époque où
le monde était fait d'esclavagé
d'exploitation mais le monde évolue les
inégalités disparaissent petit à petit
nous ressentons le poids du passé mais
il faut aussi qu'on tire profit de ce
que les blancs et abandonné sur place
créer un meilleur avenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l' empire portugais a fait de sao tomé
et principe est un des plus importants
producteurs de cacao au monde
laisse derrière ses exploits commerciaux
une population aux racines diverses qui
apprend depuis 40 ans à vivre libre et
ensemble
le destin de l'archipel semble être
aujourd'hui entre les mains de sa jeune
génération
[Applaudissements]
le pays est aujourd'hui à la croisée des
chemins laissant tôt mais un peuvent
désormais devenir maîtres de leur avenir
en protégeant son environnement en
misant sur l'éducation ou encore en se
réappropriant ces systèmes de production
sao tomé possède toutes les clés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment le pays va-t-il gérer les
cicatrices de son passé et faire face
aux défis de la mondialisation
il faut se rappeler que le tivoli est
une pièce de théâtre plein de
rebondissements propre os en tome est un
c'est une tragédie mais une tragédie qui
finit bien